has her husband ever made a stock  purchase or sale basically  no  absolutely not  okay  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  somehow she still believes that none of  us will notice  [Music]  use of chemical weapons  she's so twitchy  [Music]  [Music]  see  [Music]  first clash of flight for free  she's high society  she's got the best of everything  so they know that we can't but it's the  s from taxpayers just like me  unwilling supporters  she's brittle as she can be  hope no one ever drops her no it's just  i have tried to be gracious  society  [Music]  what  i like older women  with large  slightly floppy breasts  yeah me too  [Music]  did you even know about that trip  [Music]  she comes to speak to me  slurring words on the tv  cause what she said sounds so [ __ ]  patrick's name is now so  cause somehow she's already  at least 14  [Music]  good drinks know where she belongs the  betty ford clinic  [Music]  [Music]  look at them  she's  you